which in theory are trying to do that
are being constrained.
But perhaps even more important,
we heard before about the one percent,
the 99 percent.
If the state is thought about in this more strategic way,
as one of the lead players in the value creation mechanism,
because that's what we're talking about, right?
Who are the different players in creating value
in the economy, and is the state's role,
has it been sort of dismissed as being a backseat player?
If we can actually have a broader theory
of value creation and allow us to actually admit
what the state has been doing and reap something back,
it might just be that in the next round,
and I hope that we all hope that the next big revolution
will in fact be green,
that that period of growth
will not only be smart, innovation-led,
not only green, but also more inclusive,
so that the public schools in places like Silicon Valley
can actually also benefit from that growth,
because they have not.
Thank you.
(Applause)